Here you can see Hierarchy Viewer,
let's you select from a list of devices
both physical and virtual on the left,
each of which then contains,
each of the running activities
and applications running on that device.
You simply select the activity
from the application
that you want to profile.
Then the LoadView Hierarchy button here,
and you'll see a representation
of the selected activity's
entire View hierarchy
represented here in the TreeView,
from left to right.
You can see that the entire hierarchy
is also show here, in the overview,
and the layout itself
is shown in a wireframe here.
Clicking on any view,
at any point within the hierarchy,
will show you what is displayed,
showing us the number of Views
which are contained within the hierarchy
from this point onwards.
You can also obtain
the performance metrics
to find out how long it takes
to measure, layout and draw
each element of the hierarchy.
It's a powerful tool, and you can
find out more about how to use it
to optimize your layouts and Views
in the videos and guides
linked to from the instructor notes below.
For now, note that we can use it
to find surprisingly deeply nested layouts
that need to be flattened.
For example, here we have
a layout we can describe
using one of two techniques.
One solution is using
two nested LinearLayouts.
But a better solution would be
using a RelativeLayout.
The RelativeLayout is one level shallower.
Another tip is to avoid using
the FrameLayout as the root for layout
that will always be inserted
as a child into another one.
In these circumstances, the merge tag
is a better alternative.
This will be eliminated when the layout
is included into the parents' hierarchy.
To help you remember
all of these tips and tips,
Android has a powerful
static analysis tool called Lint.
As you can see here in the Lint window,
in addition to the layout warnings
we've already talked about,
it also checks from everything
from accessibility problems,
missing translations,
and hard coded strings.
You can find all the things lint checks for
at the developer tools page
linked to in the instructor notes.